back in August it was announced that the
actor James Franco had been cast to play
Fidel Castro in an upcoming film as
axios reported at the time the casting
decision sparked anger many on the left
accused Franco of participating in
whitewashing the Washington Post ran an
article claiming that the incident
highlights the alleged ongoing problem
of Latino exclusion in Hollywood fellow
actor John Leguizamo blasted the casting
as appropriation called for a boycott
many others agree that Franco should not
be allowed to appropriate a brutal
dictator from Latinos he may be a mass
murdering psychopath but he's there Mass
murdering psychopath damn it it didn't
matter that Franco actually looks a lot
like Fidel Castro it also didn't matter
that Franco and Castro are not that far
apart ethnically Castro's father was
from Spain while Franco's grandfather's
from Portugal it also of course didn't
matter that the job of an actor is to
act that it is to pretend to be
something that you are not none of that
matters in such cases all that matters
is that Franco is white
and white people must stay in their
acting Lane now by the way John
Leguizamo was born in Colombia but his
first prominent role in Hollywood was
portraying the Nintendo character uh
Luigi who is an Italian plumber
according to the Nintendo Canon that
doesn't matter either though as we'll
cover in a moment
now over the years there have been many
outrages and controversy stemming from
instances of alleged whitewashing the
anger is no less palpable when the role
in question is a fictional character in
2017 a British actor was forced to drop
out of a Hellboy film because the
character he was supposed to play was
Japanese in the original comic a few
years before that Emma Stone's casting
as an Asian woman in a romantic comedy
provokes so much wrath from the left
that the director of the film had to
issue a written apology for the film he
directed and stone herself has since
apologized for her participation in the
project that same year Rooney Mara had
to grovel and beg for forgiveness after
starring as tiger lily in a Peter Pan
adaptation the left declared that the
fictional character is supposed to be
Native American Rooney Mara is not and
she agreed and now she says that she's
haunted by guilt because of uh
portraying that character in the film
The outrage extends into the cartoon
realm as well where last year a Hank
Azaria famously apologized and announced
that he was stepping away from his role
as a poo in The Simpsons on the basis
that he shouldn't be voicing a character
of Indian descent in fact the show's
producers
have since said that no white voice
actors will be used for any characters
from other ethnic backgrounds from now
on
the determination to root out all cases
of whitewashing quote unquote or
suspected whitewashing or potential
whitewashing is so absolute that the
live-action remake of Aladdin in 2019
came under Fire because the brown
actress who played Jasmine was not brown
enough now she wasn't white but she
appeared to be kind of white adjacent
and that was very disturbing a Screen
Rant article at the time said that
Aladdin's whitewashing had damaged its
box office potential
the writer apparently convinced that the
average moviegoer shares her race
obsessed neurosis
now it may then come as a surprise
to the most naive Among Us anyway
that the very same media which complains
bitterly about whites in traditionally
non-white roles and the very same
leftists who treat the the whitening of
non-white characters as literal genocide
and all the people who've taken this
issue so seriously as to cause many
white Hollywood actors to drop out of
films and fall to their knees in apology
would all this week be so excited about
the release of the first trailer for
Disney's upcoming Little Mermaid
live-action copy and paste job now
everything is mostly the same in the
remake as always it's like shot for shot
exactly said except
that The Little Mermaid herself a pale
redhead in the cartoon version has been
recast as a black woman though still
with red hair somehow
this is part of a growing Trend as the
anger about whitewashing increases
so an equal proportion does the demand
for what we must in the reverse call
Black washing a viral post on Twitter
declares rapturously a black Cinderella
a black Bell on Broadway a black
Cinderella on Broadway and now a black
Ariel the black girls are truly winning
much the left's approval the black girls
are winning quote unquote in historical
retellings too last year a black woman
was cast as Anne Boleyn the 16th century
Queen of England in an upcoming
miniseries Netflix currently features a
show starring a black woman as a Viking
Warrior
many other examples come to mind too
many to count they even fired Jake from
State Farm and replaced him with a black
version
and then there are the examples yet to
be for instance there's still a major
push to find somebody other than a white
man to fill James Bond's shoes in the
next installment
now in all of these cases
two things are guaranteed or actually
more than two a few things
when when a black actor plays a
traditionally white role portraying
either a fictional character or a
historical figure
the media the left and Hollywood itself
will celebrate the move as pioneering
and courageous and important along with
all the other requisite superlatives
the other guarantee is that any
criticism of the casting decision even
and especially criticism that simply
adopts the same logic as the left
applies to so-called whitewashing will
be slammed as racist
The Daily Beast today has an article
documenting what it calls the racist
backlash to the black Little Mermaid
declaring this backlash to be out of
control the racism is out of control
they say
then you click on the article
and in the article they provide a few
tweets from random accounts complaining
that the underwater scenes don't look
realistic so The Daily Beast article
about racist backlash contains no racist
backlash or even backlash that vaguely
mentions race
they simply determined that the
criticism of the film's bad CGI is
really racially motivated it's a dog
whistle as they like to say
that's the third guarantee that when a
film casts a black actor in a white role
any criticism of the film
any criticism even criticism makes no
mention of race
is racist which is why you can't
criticize the new Lord of the Rings
series or the Game of Thrones prequel
without revealing yourself to be a
member of the KKK
in such situations
the left also likes to employ its
favorite slight of hand trick that we
talk about all the time on this show
this is something that they will surely
use in response to this very monologue
you're listening to right now when media
matter Media Matters Clips it and posts
it to Twitter with a caption like daily
wire host launches into racist tirade
about black Little Mermaid guaranteed
they're going to do that and when they
do the left is going to going to respond
to it by scoffing and saying well why do
you care so much it's just a movie about
a mermaid it's just a mini series about
the Queen of England it's just a show
about a viking it's just entertainment
why are you even talking about this
aren't there more important issues
but of course they themselves have made
exceedingly clear that racial accuracy
and entertainment whether fictional or
historical is extremely important to
them they've been saying this for years
that's why they go into spasms of rage
whenever a character is judged not black
or brown enough
it's why they would literally Riot and
start killing people if somebody
rebooted Tyler Perry's Medea series
except with Bob Odenkirk dressed in drag
for the title role
a similar reaction would be expected if
the live-action remake of The Princess
and the Frog featured like Kristen
Stewart as Tatiana and of course a
biopic about say Frederick Douglass with
Tom Hanks as the lead would result in
entire cities burning down in flames
all of these things would be called
as less egregious examples have been
called black Erasure
so does that not mean by their own
categorization
that the reverse is white Erasure
and if they can complain about black
Erasure then why Can't We complain about
white Erasure any kind of Erasure on
racial grounds sounds bad to me
well no they say it's different in the
reverse it's just different
it always is right
and that's why all of this matters now
on its own in a vacuum
the race of an actor portraying a
fictional character or even a historical
character doesn't matter makes no
difference right that's exactly the
point that many of us have insisted on
for years when the left started making
this an issue for years we said it's not
an issue who cares and there was a time
when when that was the case it wasn't an
issue nobody really cared about it
Morgan Freeman's character and Shawshank
Redemption is actually supposed to be an
Irish guy with red hair that's why the
character is named red
but nobody complained because Freeman
was brilliant in the role he
single-handedly made that film The
Classic that it is and also back in the
early 90s people weren't obsessing as
much about the racial Dynamics in
Hollywood films there was nothing
pointed or political about giving the
role to Freeman
contrary to now when the diversification
quote unquote of a story is always very
clearly pointed and political
back then he was just the best man for
the job everyone loves his character now
and that's all that needs to be said
many of us have clung to that attitude
today which again in a vacuum makes
sense
but we're not in a vacuum
unfortunately we live now in a culture
governed by blatant racial double
standards the the rightness or wrongness
of an act
the seriousness or unseriousness of an
issue
the legitimacy or illegitimacy of a
complaint
even the mutability or immutability of a
cartoon character's race are all judged
on racial grounds
based on skin color we are told what our
opinions are allowed to be and what
sorts of things we are allowed to care
about
and if you're white
then there's going to be a whole list of
things that every other group of people
can care about but which you would be
insane stupid Petty and racist to care
about yourself
entire lists of priorities which due to
your skin pigmentation are off limits
for you
you are not allowed to care about it
they say
we're supposed to just accept a rule
which says you know having a white actor
play Black Panther is horribly racist
but it's also horribly racist to
complain about a black actor playing The
Little Mermaid
but that rule is indefensible and
hypocritical in the extreme
and we all know it and yet we're
supposed to just acquiesce to it
that's what all this is about in the end
it's not about the movies I don't even
watch any of these movies
on their own I don't care about them
I do care about the racial double
standard which we are being conditioned
to accept
because another word for racial double
standard is racism
this is all racist
and that's why it matters
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the Subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast